السعوديه تدخل مجال الابحاث الفضاء لخدمه
العلم والبشريه عنوان كشفت عنه الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء وكتبت الهيئه عن المهام
والابحاث العلميه التي سيتم ارجائها خلال
رحله رائده ورائده فضاء سعوديه اريانا
برناوي وعلي القرني والتي ستكون في الربع
الثاني من العام الحالي ضمن مهمه فضائيه
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه اي اس اس ومدتها
عشره ايام وسيتم خلال المهمه اجراء 14
تجربه بحثيه علميه سته منها في الدماغ
واربعه منها في الخلايا البشريه وواحده
منا في الاستمطار وثلاثه تجارب تعليميه
توعويه في الجاذبيه الصغرى خلال المهمه
سيتم معرفه مدى التكيف البشري في رحلات
الفضاء وفهم تاثيرات التواجد في الفضاء
على صحه الانسان وتحديد ما اذا كانت رحلات
الفضاء امنه على الدماغ البشري وتهدف
الهيئه الى اشراق الطلاب في التجارب
العلميه اذ سيتمكنون من التواصل مع رواد
الفضاء السعوديين مباشره باجراء تجاربهم
معا وقالت الهيئه نتائج هذه التجارب ستعزز
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء وخدمه البشريه لتعزيز الشركات
الدوليه
[موسيقى]